VETO ANY CRITICAL RESOLUTION
THAT MAKES ITS WAY TO HIS DESK.
CONSERVATIVES FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY ARE IN SUBURBAN
WASHINGTON TONIGHT FOR THEIR
ANNUAL CONFERENCE KNOWN AS A C
PACK.
CORRESPONDENT DOUG McKELWAY'S
LIFE AND THE NATIONAL HARBOR
MARYLAND TO TELL US THE BIG
TOPIC IS WITH THE DEMOCRATS
DOING TO EACH OTHER.
>> AT A TIME OF HISTORICALLY LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT AND ECONOMIC
EXPANSION AND SERVANT OF SEA
ADVANTAGE OF THE LEFTWARD LURCH
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THE LATEST EXAMPLE, THE GREEN
NEW DEAL.
>> TO PAY FOR THE GREAT NEW
DEAL, KEEP BORROWING AND
BORROWING.
THIS IS SUCH A NAIVE THOUGHT IN
THE WORLD OF DEBT THAT I CAN'T
EVEN RESPOND TO IT.
>> THE LEFT TILT AS A TARGET
RICH ENVIRONMENT FROM THE
ALLEGED HOAXES OF JUSSIE
SMOLLETT, THE COVINGTON KIDS AND
LATE-TERM ABORTIONS, THE
SCANDALS OF VIRGINIA POLITICS TO
THE RECENT DISCOVERY OF A
BERNIE SANDERS QUOTE ABOUT THE
GOODNESS OF FOOD LINES.
>> IN OTHER COUNTRIES PEOPLE
DON'T LINE UP FOR FOOD.
>> BERNIE SANDERS WAS TALKING
ABOUT IT'S GOING TO BE IN LINE
TO WAIT FOR FOOD?
WE HAVE TO GO TO A POINT WHERE
WE CELEBRATE CAPITALISM.
>> THAT IS THE OTHER THEME OF C
PACK THIS YEAR.
>> 3% GROWTH AS FAR AS THE EYE
CAN SEE.
IT IS THE HOTTEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND I WILL LET THE ANKLE
FIGHTERS JUST BITE OUR ANKLES.
>> CONFRONTING THOSE
EXPRESSIONS, THEY ARE EMBRACING
SOCIALISM IN A FAR LEFT AGENDA.
>> THIS IS NOW A VOTING ISSUE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE GREAT GENERATION HAS RISEN
UP.
>> THAT WHILE THE G.O.P. REMAINS
OLDER AND LARGELY WHITE.
C PACK ORGANIZERS ARE INTENT ON
CHANGING THAT, THIS BREAKOUT
SESSION WITH YOUNG MINORITIES.
MANY FACE DAUNTING PEER PRESSURE
IS ONE EXAMPLE.
>> YOU PEOPLE COME UP TO YOU AND
SAY YOU HATE YOURSELF AND YOU
WERE UNCLE TOM.
>> HE IS PREACHING TO HIS
FOLLOWERS WHILE HAYDEN WILLIAMS
INVITED TO    TO C PACK WILL PUN
INVITED TO    TO C PACK WILL PUH
INVITED TO    TO C PACK WILL PUO
INVITED TO    TO C PACK WILL PUT
AT BERKELEY KEPT HIS CAMERA
ROLLING.
>> I'M SURE 10 MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE SEEN IT.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN EMBRACING
SOCIAL MEDIA, BUT THEY'RE DOING
IT NOW.